WHEN THE RIGHT SONG BECOMES
A PART OF THE RIGHT MOVIE,
IT STAYS WITH US FOREVER.
YOU CAN NEVER HEAR THAT SONG
AGAIN WITHOUT THINKING
ABOUT ITS MOVIE PARTNER.
THAT IS THE POWER OF MUSIC.
ALTHOUGH MOST OF THE NOMINEES
WERE ABLE TO MAKE IT TO
LOS ANGELES, THERE ARE A PAIR
JOINING US FROM SWEDEN.
SO, HERE ARE THE NOMINEES
FOR BEST SONG.
AND THE OSCAR GOES TO --
H.E.R., DERNST EMILE II,
AND TIARA THOMAS
"FIGHT FOR YOU" FROM "JUDAS AND
THE BLACK MESSIAH”
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
OH MY GOD.
I DID NOT EXPECT
TO WIN THIS AWARD.
I AM SO, SO, SO, SO GRATEFUL.
NOT ONLY TO WIN,
BUT TO BE A PART OF SUCH
AN IMPORTANT, IMPORTANT STORY.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU TO THE ACADEMY.
I’VE ALWAYS WANTED
TO SAY THAT.
AND OF COURSE,
MY COLLABORATORS, D’MILE
AND TIARA THOMAS,
THIS SONG WOULDN’T BE
WHAT IT WAS WITHOUT THEM.
OF COURSE, I HAVE TO
THANK GOD FOR GIVING US
THESE GIFTS AND MY PARENTS,
MY BEAUTIFUL MOTHER WHO’S
HERE WITH ME TODAY
AND MY FATHER AT HOME.
ALL THOSE DAYS OF LISTENING
TO SLY AND THE FAMILY STONE,
AND CURTIS MAYFIELD AND MARVIN
GAYE, THEY REALLY PAID OFF.
SO THANK YOU, DAD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO ARCHIE
AND SHAKA KING AND EVERYBODY
THAT WAS INVOLVED IN THIS MOVIE
AND GAVE ME THE CALL AND
GAVE US THE CALL TO DO THIS RECORD.
I’M SO, SO GRATEFUL.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THIS.
YOU KNOW MUSICIANS, FILMMAKERS,
I BELIEVE WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
AND A RESPONSIBILITY, TO ME,
TO TELL THE TRUTH AND TO
WRITE HISTORY THE WAY THAT IT WAS
AND HOW IT CONNECTS US TO TODAY
AND WHAT WE SEE GOING ON IN
THE WORLD TODAY.
AND YEAH, I’M JUST, I HAVE NO WORDS,
I’M JUST SO, SO, SO HAPPY AND GRATEFUL
AND YEAH, KNOWLEDGE IS POWER.
MUSIC IS POWER.
AND AS LONG AS
I’M STANDING,
I’M ALWAYS GOING
TO FIGHT FOR US.
I’M ALWAYS GOING TO FIGHT FOR
MY PEOPLE AND FIGHT FOR
WHAT’S RIGHT, AND I THINK THAT’S
WHAT MUSIC DOES.
AND THAT’S WHAT
STORYTELLING DOES.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.